jets linebacker cj mosley stunned
everyone earlier this week by opting out
of the 2020 season
what he said about it yesterday that's
probably the biggest football decision
i've made in a long time probably since
i picked what college i'm going to so
that's a book i got to start writing
pretty soon figure out what's the next
step because there's a lot of negative
things people can say as far as me not
playing two years and there's a lot of
positive things that can be said i'm out
all year so i have this time to mentally
get better physically get better kind of
readjust and kind of find that flame
again now last year cj mosley played in
only two games for the jets he was a
force of nature in week one against the
bills as the jets built a 16 nothing
first half lead that they inevitably
would squander because that's what the
jets do but one of the reasons why that
happened was mosley got injured right
and he was gone most of the year and
look we
we don't pay enough attention to what
these guys go through
and
even though you can look at what he said
and say oh he's taking advantage of the
opt out
potential to address other concerns or
other issues you can also look at it and
say the pandemic concern is that last
straw that breaks the camel's back sure
where you've got a lot of things you're
worried about you're trying to
rediscover your passion they just traded
jamal adams for crying out loud how good
are we even going to be this year you
throw everything into a blender and that
last factor of worrying about playing
football in a pandemic maybe the thing
that gets you to say you know what i'm
going to conscientiously take a step
back this year take this year off i'll
come back next year and i'll be much
better next year than i would have been
this year yeah maybe that's what he's
thinking well i mean listen i i don't
doubt that you know i understand it you
know yeah it's it's a middle linebacker
playing football is you know playing in
alabama we know that nick saban likes to
coach his guys tough their physical
practices you know plays for the
baltimore ravens you know you know
they're tough physical everything they
do there so yeah his body has you know
taken a beating certainly and i i i feel
for linebackers or most football players
from from that standpoint all the time
the the thing that's interesting to me
here
is you know not that it's a a cop-out or
a money grab but this to me is the case
of something we've talked about the last
few weeks a guy that first off is in a
contract situation where he's kind of
got the team you know
by the kahunas for lack of a better
phrase there right he's got him so that
they don't really have anything they can
do here because they've offered them and
paid them a lot of money and have a lot
more money that they do owe them so
there's that standpoint but i just think
it's the comments at the end that you
know as an ex-football player here and
again you know like we just talked about
beat up body yes the virus i'm sensitive
to all that but i'm just telling you as
a football player in a locker room when
i read that kind of thing i go oh
this guy sounds like he just might not
be ready to play football this year
period you know when you hear mentally
physically regain the flame you know
what did i say to you in text yesterday
i said well this sounds like rocky iii
like mick is trying to tell rocky balboa
like you became civilized kid you're not
ready for this kind of battle anymore
you know like and that's the kind of guy
that we've been talking about who's
going to get talked about in the locker
room you know everybody's going to be
cool to him nobody's going to say
anything publicly but i do believe it's
this type of situation where an
organization the coaches the players
they're going to give them the side eye
next year when he walks in the locker
and they're going to be like
man you we've paid you a lot of money
you've got 19 million dollars so far for
one game and and then you know last year
you know you so that i'm just saying
that that's all i'm trying to say i'm
sensitive to it i get it but this is a
player i think that's what's going to go
through a lot of guys heads
and then he goes out on the field and he
pops somebody and the side eye becomes
the wide eye well that's when they
realize cj mosley's still got it that's
what
that's what it'll have to be you're
exactly right that was what will change
the time because he's going to be there
because of his contract and everything
they're kind of stuck with them no
matter what he's not going to be one of
those guys that they can cut next year
but you're right that's where it all be
judged on if he can come back and like
you said after a year off be better and
and you know flying around the field and
all that it'll be forgiven very quickly
if not and he's kind of faltering or you
know a little slow in his game uh the
side eye will continue and and maybe
more
here's the key though they didn't have
him
for the vast majority of last season
right they'd had him all year yeah it
would be a much tougher adjustment
what's the change we got used to playing
without cj mosley sure last year
although it would be nice to have cj
mosley while you're in the process of
getting used to playing without exactly
jamal adams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports